prise de parole du président de la
république pour moi c'est de la
communication politique on est une
nouvelle fois dans l'affichage je
rappelle qu'on connaît l'existence des
vaccins depuis le mois de novembre nous
sommes au 1er avril on est un des pays
au monde les moins vacciner on a la
grande bretagne qui est très en avance
sur la deuxième dose sur la première
dose on n'est même pas à 4 millions de
français vaccinés on a des gens qui
peinent à trouver des rendez-vous pour
premières loges en herbe oui certes mais
bon il faut quand même avoir la deuxième
dose donc on voit qu'il ya un retard qui
est quand même très très important et
que le gouvernement qui était en charge
de la stratégie vaccinale a voulu le
faire en interne d'abord via ministère
des affaires sociales ça a été une
catastrophe
finalement il a pris un cabinet
américain mckinsey ça coûte 2 millions
d'euros par mois et on a perdu beaucoup
de temps et si on veut s'en sortir si
les français veulent retrouver une vie
normale
il faut vacciner massivement comme là où
l'on fait la grande bretagne comme l'a
fait il rêver à quoi ça va on achète des
doses par tous les moyens pour mai mais
oui on voit d'ailleurs au niveau de
l'europe et d'astrazeneca il ya un
retard puisque par rapport au contrat il
y en a à peine la moitié qui est arrivé
et que du coup on va on va perdre du
temps donc moi je crois qu'il faut
s'approvisionner par tous les moyens au
maximum à partir du moment évidemment où
on a eu les autorisations des agences
européennes qui permettent évidemment
usage de ces vaccins mais il faut mettre
le paquet monte en puissance on peut pas
continuer des semaines des mois dans
cette situation est encore une fois seul
à illustrer la gestion erratique de
cette crise par le gouvernement on
l'avait déjà vu sur le dépistage sur les
masques sur un certain nombre de sujets
et là on réitère avec la vaccination
alors quoi que c'est une nouvelle
illustration d'un couac gouvernemental
on nous dit il ya au mois de décembre
monsieur verrons nous dit que les
vaccinodromes ça ne sert à rien et trois
mois après on change de stratégie on a
eu la même chose sur les masques
souvenez-vous lorsque des élus locaux
ont fait en sorte et bien de produire
des masques et d'en proposer à la
population dans des collectivités dans
des régions ça ne servent à rien
quelques semaines après on change de
discours et là ça a été la même chose
et au final qu'est ce qui se passe on
perd du temps les français perdent du
temps
tout ça parce qu'il ya une mauvaise
gestion et qu'on a des allers retours et
des stratégies qui sont absolument
illisible